[Applaudissements]
li na
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et s'il adore lula
bachiri tu vas tu vas tu va juger nos
mariés parce que tu vas faire bien côté
les work d'être à côté de moi que tu va
juger nos variés est ce que tu vas faire
une émission sur les robes de mariée à
notre première mariée c'est un
spécialiste du mariage puisqu'il s'est
marié tellement de fois que son salaire
se transforme automatiquement en pension
alimentaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des shérifs des échanges d'univers avec
une mariée avec un physique plutôt
différent mais qu'est-ce son petit
charme
[Applaudissements]
madonna
la caution
il est comme moi je peux dire que
l'extravagance et que ça tout d'un
vincent ce pouvaitt manif à travers que
le blanc est signe de virginité ça tombe
bien ce qu'il s'agit là de maxime qui
dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça le sert et de la magnifique ah oui
elle est magnifique elle a d'ailleurs
pâti n'est pas un stade jean michel
maire c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah mais moi je trouve qu'il a joué le
rôle à fond et bien aimé les personnages
il marche très bien talent j'adorais
cher et à une entrée triomphale et pour
cela je donne ma nissan
c'est la dernière balle et magnifique je
vous demande d'applaudir bouder
[Applaudissements]
les rebelles
à chaque fois que je me sois je suis
déguisé aux mêmes numéros tirés le fils
de la rue wilson à audrey la rizza à
larissa
[Musique]